kendrick nunn is on the floor
and uh and the handoff try
broken up the other way wore and cleaned
up by holiday
miami had pushed the lead to 10 twice
they've had a 10-point lead in this game
already
matches their biggest lead of the series
overall holiday picks deadman's pocket
dogged second consecutive start drags
pushing his way in now hero with
middleton autumn
and stolen by drew holiday holiday with
the bounce
racing by everyone and he's fouled by
dragach
i want to know bro shout out to nomar
garcia exactly
there's a turnover and drew holiday with
another steal that's his third
holiday's got middleton with him but he
pulls it back out finds lopez running
the floor
at the retool regather if
the game continues on its path right now
which would look like
you know it may be middleton will run it
down
especially game two holiday surrounded
has it taken away by durant
durant handling knocked away and stolen
as holiday will bring it up the other
way
giannis guarding durant
over to hardin who lost the handle
they back up to 11.
21 and off the turnover holliday in a
foot race
with griffin put his body into him and
drew the foul
lake griffin has done a good job this
series of trying to wall him up on that
penetration but putting him in the
screen as the screener
on the street and roll has been
effective at times for the bucks now but
harden one of the best at drawing fouls
in the history of the game the middleton
only his first foul
and the nets turn it over leading to a
foul
only seven free-throw attempts to this
point
off the turnover here's yadas fouled by
young
[Applause]
out of five seconds i'm
excellent out of timeout play there by
coach bud
and that was directed towards jonathan
all the way
honest
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
once again hawks by three
final minute third quarter bad pass
here come the box forbes wide open for
three
our truck is agreeing with you here's
donald
trump trying to get the fire on porters
for
[Applause]
[Music]
shot clock to five columns had it
knocked out of his hands
these are the times when guys who are
struggling finding ways to get the ball
in the basket
took the triple away from williams
[Applause]
these last few moments meanwhile
holloway continues to have his troubles
after the good start he's missed his
last
six shots he's connors him fourth three
yes
defense by the smaller bogdanovic on
bobby porter
[Applause]
once again tries to get it down low pass
antenna to columns
middleton at an ocean for the foul line
now
gets it to offensive rebound and gives
him gives
his team second opportunity collins
grabbed
away by holiday that's what happened in
in game five
[Music]
[Applause]
young not able to hit cancel puts it in
the hands of
reddish goes into one of the best
three-point shooters during the regular
season the former spur stolen by holiday
holiday drives leads inside left-handed
he missed it
you can see the similarities of lebron
james and giannis running with a full
head of steam whether with the
basketball
or filling the lanes tough to stop ayton
goes off
blocked first by holiday
paul fakes the three
gets into the paint blocked by holliday
through the hands of a pedocuba they're
only four of 17 from three but that one
puts them up eight again
booker against holliday inside block
from behind
holiday behind the back middleton back
to holiday
inside portis for the slam finals for
the bucks
and they've got it done on a defensive
end and off of the great defense
outstanding transition offense
willingness to turn down a good shot for
a better one
giannis appreciating the stellar job by
his teammates i tell you what
one thing monty williams said is devin
book has looked more like himself the
last couple days
had his leg under didn't make any
excuses for his poor play
turnover in that position holiday goes
back to middleton middleton inside
lays it up and in he's been a little
banged up like most players are at this
point holliday pokes it away
and then booker and that'll be a clear
path foul
mike that was one great block by yana
chris paul falls down and lost the ball
and you've got numbers right now via the
bucks
holiday middleton inside he banks it
home
chris paul with an uncharacteristic
turnover
and drew holliday a good play to
middleton
and a tough finish over booker
what a pass and a great job by middleton
moving without the basketball coach you
always talked about
his ability to slash and cut holiday
with the steal took it away from booker
and with tucker out holiday on him
booker slices inside holiday was right
there and booker turns it over
one-on-one with him baseline turnaround
won't go
bridges another rebound poked away and
stolen by holiday
booker the drive gets inside leans in
knocked away and stolen by holiday
phoenix has to foul
throws it down gets into the pitcher
comes up with the strip
turning the basketball over and then off
to the races
could have held it out instead made the
right read throws it up where only
giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact and bad
decision to foul because this would make
it
a four-point game with 13.5 remaining
phoenix still has a timeout
rolling the dice hopefully the big guy
gives us a quality minute
he tips it away dives on it lost it got
it back
fight for the ball throws it up and gets
it to middleton
all up top booker fakes guessed
perfectly by holiday
holiday drives goes inside layup he
missed it